did anybody else get a bear hug from
Batman no but oh man
we were three weeks in shooting I didn't
have no lines we were just doing all of
the basketball stuff so when we had the
scene where he introduces himself as the
coach I was so happy I'm like I finally
get to speak finally and so I remember
when I got ready to save my lions and
this guy cuts my line off it was I let
it slide I let the heater in the back
you know I did it because he did it one
more time and I was like oh no this I'm
not gonna do I'm not taking this fry
don't Ben Affleck cool so I just
remember I was talking with Melbourne in
the group I said I'm about to tell Ben
Affleck off and they were like you know
are you crazy don't do it and I ran over
it and I sprinted and I hit it right on
the chest aside hey I was like hey man
you stepping on my lines what's up with
that you know I mean I'm proud of my lot
I've been waiting a minute I told him
Ben Affleck you're Ben Affleck you were
in this movie you got all the lines Oh
got that mini life I need all the
chances I could get and I had the script
and I was telling them that why oh my
gosh this story has grown
I stepped on a line what's his line was
what I was like this guy is not going to
let any my line is subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe please
don't make me keep going